it is what you see on your screen there
a huge fire in the west valley
leveled an apartment complex under
construction we have team coverage of
the fire and the evacuations
we're going to start with hector mejia
who is live at the senior tropicana and
fort apache with the latest
hector good morning hey there good
morning crews right now still working on
hot spots and i just wanted to show you
this is one of several businesses
that were so close to the scene of the
fire out there you can see firefighters
still
soaking hot spots we can see some hoses
on right now
and off in the distance i can actually
see a flare up right now this is we're
told
more than 200 luxury apartment units
that were under construction
now considered a total loss uh
firefighters have been out here since
about midnight as many as a hundred
firefighters from multiple departments
this is directly behind the crossroads
plaza shopping center
near fort apache and tropicana the clark
county fire department tells us this was
the eli
at ford apache project it was halfway
done
a huge setback not only for the project
but also for future residents according
to the website
that were already pre-leasing for
february of this year
we rushed out here as soon as we got
word of this breaking news and we
captured some of the earlier flames at
one point
the flames appeared to shoot hundreds of
feet into the air
it looked like an inferno we're told
this is one of the biggest for some of
the firefighters out here
thankfully no reports of injuries this
morning
clark county las vegas north las vegas
and henderson fire departments all
responded
and the winds made this incredibly
difficult for them to put it out some
areas saw 30
mile per hour wind gusts overnight and
right now it's still too dangerous for
fire crews to start looking into the
paws out here
but again a lot of activity going on
right now our live team coverage
continues with bianca holmen bianca you
have
a different vantage point of this
situation and you also have
some incredible images captured by
viewers of what looked like a massive
fireball overnight
yeah hector we are on the south side of
this fire and there are in addition to
the fire crews out here there's
construction crews out here
helping to move some of the construction
that's out here because again this was
an apartment complex in the works and
we're at the apache plaza so again
businesses and homes just steps away
from this massive fire
we received dozens of pictures and video
from folks at home who were steps away
from this fire
and there were these pictures where the
flames were so high they could be seen
from the 215 highway and the smoke
being carried away by the heavy winds
also some more pictures from different
angles firefighters at work tearing
through the fence to control the blaze
and also pictures from the gas station
shows you just how dangerous this fire
was to the surrounding areas
and then finally video from a viewer at
an apartment complex a scary sight for
people waking up to sirens overnight
of course being woken up by the winds
overnight
and coming up in the next half hour
we're going to talk about some of the
evacuations that were happening in this
area because of this fire
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now
going to send it back to you guys in the
studio all right bianca thank you very
much so we'll continue to follow the
fire on air and online with all the
details you need to know about
what's going on out there in the west
part of the valley just head to
8newsnow.com for the latest information